après 28 années au service du racing
d'ancenis me claude verret s'entraîne
aujourd'hui les herbiers qui évolue en
division d'honneur fidélité et travail
ce sont les maîtres mots de celui que
l'on appelait le sorcier de la davrays
lorsqu'à ancenis il a connu les joies de
la deuxième division
pourtant rien ne laissait présager un
tel parcours sur les bords de loire il
claude perez est arrivé en 1965 à ce
moment-là ancenis évoluer en division
régionale d'honneur aujourd'hui lycos
berès estime qu'il doit beaucoup au
football grâce au football j'ai réussi
une promotion sociale grâce aux pubs
vial j'ai beaucoup voyagé je connais
beaucoup de pays grâce au football je
connais j'ai connu des gens très
intéressants des gens très très très
positif dans ma carrière j'ai rencontré
des gens qui m'ont porté énormément et
je crois que
cantona a fait carrière dans le football
pendant 45 ans
on est enrichi de l'expérience humaine
qui vont peut-être
les choses le plus cher qui existe dans
ma carrière de joueur et entraîneur
son meilleur souvenir restera
l'accession parmi l'élite avec le racing
club lens ni deux années en deuxième
division ça ne s'oublie pas après 28 ans
de service miklos et ancenis se séparent
ça non plus ça ne s'oublie pas
j'avais vraiment envie de changer
d'autres mots ça j'avais vraiment envie
de me réinvestisse dans un club neuf
repartir avec un challenge reebok et je
crois que
j'ai pensé que j'étais honnête en
annonçant que je quitterais le club à la
fin de saison
le nouveau départ c'est ici aux herbiers
cueilli claude perez a choisi de le
prendre
actuellement en division d'honneur
l'objectif est de rejoindre le niveau
national
[Musique]